لواء فايزه الدويري الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي لواء فايز ما الذي يلفت نظرك
يعني ضمن هذه الحرب الممتده والمستمره
من الناحيه العسكريه من ناحيه النسق
العسكريه ومن ناحيه الخطط من كلا الجانبين
يعني الان يعني اكثر من جانب لكن دعيني
الخص الاجابه اقول منذ عده اسابيع انخفضت
وتيره المعارك من كلا الجانبين واصبح
التركيز على القصف المدفعي الصاروخي
استخدام
نشهد خلال الثلاثه اسابيع الماضيه ايت
معركه حاسمه من كلا طرفي القتال فرغم
الهجوم الروسي في الشمال
مع محاوله الوصول الى لمن ونهر اسكل لعل
ينجح في تحقيق موضع قدم باتجاه
لكن الامور لا تسير بوتيره جيده يقابل ذلك
الحديث عن فاقمت واليد العليا يفترض نظريا
انها للجانب الاوكراني كذلك لا يحقق
انجازات والخسائر
التي التقدم اعتزاولوجيا نستطيع القول بان
المعارك الحاسمه لم نشهدها منذ اكثر من
شهر والحديث عن تكمل وغير ذلك والذهاب
باتجاه ميلوتوبل لم نعد نشهده كذلك في
منطقه خرسون فبالتالي ما هو البديل البديل
التكليف باستخدام الوسائل المتاحه
والممكنه كانت اليد العليا للجانب الروسي
في اوديسيا في خاصه بعد
استهداف جسر القرم او جسر كرش والقوات
الاوكرانيه تحاول ان ترد لتضع معادله نوع
من التوازن اي بالحديث عن
مقابل تدمير الموانئ اذا الفتره الحاليه
هي فتره استخدام الوسائل المتاحه وتحديدا
الطائرات المسيره طيب اللواء فايزه سريعا
ان اردنا ان نربط بين تصريحات الرئيس
زيلينسكي والتي يقول فيها بانه لا مفر من
وصول الحرب الى الداخل الروسي اذا ما
ربطنا هذه التصريحات بما يحصل فعليا
وتحديدا هذه الضربات الاخيره بالمسيرات
سواء في قلب العاصمه الروسيه موسكو او في
شبه جزيره القرم يعني كيف يمكن اعتبار هذا
الامر هو جزء يعني من اي استراتيجيه
يتبعها الجانب الاوكراني
من وجهه نظر عسكريه
اصلا هذا الرد الاوكراني متاخر جدا
واستخدام هذه الوسائل متاخر جدا لماذا
لانه اوكرانيا تعتبر ما يجري هو حاله حرب
معلنه من روسيا على اوكرانيا روسيا تقول
عمليه عسكريه خاصه ما هي الوسائل المتاحه
لدى الجانب الاوكراني لتحقيق بعض
الانجازات او الحاق بعض الايلان في الجانب
الاخر من حيث القدرات بشان هجمات داخل
الاراضي الروسيه لا يوجد الا الطائرات
المسيره فبالتالي انا كمحلل كنت استغرب
لماذا لا يتم استخدامها منذ اشهر ولكن منذ
الهجوم على قاعده انجلز حققوا انجازا
عسكريا بتدمير بعض الطائرات بدات الان
العالي العسكريه الاوكرانيه تركز على هذا
البعد في فتره من الفترات كان هناك عمليات
وفي العمليات ارضيه ولكنها توقفت وبالتالي
اعتبرها جزء من الاوراق الرابحه بيد
اوكرانيا من اجل احداث ضغط
نعم
سنكتفي بهذا شكرا لك كنت معنا من عمان
لواء فايزه دويريا الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي